ELECTIONS, BREAKING NEWS, CAPE
GIRARDEAU, MISSOURI.
OPENING MONOLOGUE.
♪ ♪
TWO YEARS AGO AMERICANS FROM ALL
OVER THE COUNTRY WENT TO THE
POLLS.
THEY CAST THEIR BALLOTS FOR
DONALD J. TRUMP AND VIRTUALLY
ALL OF THE POLITICAL PUNDITS AND
ANALYSTS, SO-CALLED JOURNALIST
AND POLLS POSTERS PREDICTED A
HUGE WIN FOR HILLARY AND THEY
WERE ALL DEAD WRONG.
AMERICANS, YOU SHOCK THE WORLD
AND EVER SINCE THE TRUMP AGENDA
HAS BEEN PAYING MASSIVE
DIVIDENDS IN JUST TWO SHORT
YEARS.
THE ECONOMY IS BOOMING,
4.5 MILLION NEW JOBS AND
4.3 MILLION FEWER AMERICANS ON
FOOD STAMPS.
4 MILLION AMERICANS LIFTED OUT
OF POVERTY ON THE MANUFACTURING
FRONT.
OBAMA SAID THESE JOBS ARE NEVER
COMING BACK.
400,000 NEW JOBS.
UNEMPLOYMENT CLAIMS ARE AT A 49
YEAR LOW IN JUST TWO YEARS.
RECORD LOW UNEMPLOYMENT FOR
AFRICAN-AMERICANS, HISPANIC
HISPANIC AMERICANS,
ASIAN-AMERICANS AND HISTORIC
UNEMPLOYMENT FOR WOMEN IN THE
WORKPLACE.
THESE ARE ALL RECORDS.
AND FOR MILITARY DOCTRINES AND A
YOUTH UNEMPLOYMENT, MEDIAN
HOUSEHOLD INCOME HITTING RECORD
HIGHS.
4.2% GDP GROWTH IN THE SECOND
QUARTER, 3.5% IN THE MOST RECENT
QUARTER.
THIS ALL COMES AS
PRESIDENT TRUMP SLASHED
REGULATIONS, PROMISES MADE,
PROMISES KEPT.
THAT COMES AFTER HE SIGNED OF
THE SINGLE BIGGEST MIDDLE-CLASS
PACKED TAX CUT HISTORY.
PROMISE MADE IS A PROMISE KEPT.
HE OPENED UP AMERICAN ENERGY AND
WE ARE ON A PATH TOWARDS ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE.
THE KEYSTONE PIPELINE, CLICK THE
CODE ACCESS PIPELINE, A PROMISE
MADE, A PROMISE KEPT.
NEGOTIATING NEW TRADE DEALS IN
EUROPE, RENEGOTIATING NAFTA.
PULLED US OUT OF THE JOB KILLING
PARIS ACCORD.
PROMISES MADE, PROMISES KEPT.
HE PULLED US OUT OF THE
ONE-SIDED RIDICULOUS INSANITY OF
THE NUCLEAR DEAL.
WE ARE NO LONGER DROPPING CARGO
PLANES OF CASH ON A TARMAC.
ADDRESSING THE LOOMING PRICES IN
NORTH KOREA, KEEPING THE PROMISE
THAT SO MANY OTHER PRESIDENTS
MADE IT, HE'S THE ONLY ONE TO
KEEP THIS PROMISE OF MOVING THE
EMBASSY IN JERUSALEM AND, ISRAEL
TO JERUSALEM.
PROMISES MADE, PROMISES KEPT.
AND DESPITE BEING OUT OF THE
OFFICE FOR TWO YEARS, THIS IS
THE JOKE OF ALL JOKES.
WATCHING OBAMA THIS WEEKEND,
OBAMA HAD THE WORST RECORD OF
ANY PRESIDENT IN MODERN HISTORY
AND I WILL POINT OUT THAT HE
WILL TAKE CREDIT FOR TRUMP'S
SUCCESS, OR HE TRIES.
WATCH THIS.
>> WHEN YOU HEAR ALL THIS TALK
ABOUT ECONOMIC MIRACLES RIGHT
NOW, REMEMBER WHO STARTED IT.
REMEMBER WHO STARTED IT.
>> Sean: LET'S REMIND YOU THE
VOTERS WHO THE ACTUAL RECORDS
ARE.
IT'S HUMILIATING AND
EMBARRASSING.
EIGHT YEARS OF OBAMA, 8 MILLION
MORE AMERICANS ARE ON FOOD
STAMPS.
8 MILLION WAR ON POVERTY.
THE LOWEST PARTICIPATION RATE
SINCE THE 70s, LOWEST RECOVERY
SINCE -- HE WAS THE ONLY
PRESIDENT IN U.S. HISTORY NEVER
TO EXPERIENCE 3% GDP GROWTH IN A
SINGLE YEAR OF HIS PRESIDENCY.
AND LIKE GUY THAT CLAIMED
$9 TRILLION IN DEBT, THAT'S
IRRESPONSIBLE, AND UNPATRIOTIC.
IN EIGHT YEARS OF OBAMA, HE TOOK
ON MORE DEBT THAN EVERY OTHER
PRESIDENT BEFORE HIM COMBINED.
THAT WAS TWO YEARS AGO.
TODAY, PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS BEEN
MAKING A FINAL PITCH TO VOTERS
AND AN OP ED ON FOX NEWS AND THE
MESSAGE IS CLEAR.
IF YOU WANT MORE SAFETY AND
SECURITY AND PROSPERITY FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WANT, FROM ALL
WALKS OF LIFE, THIS IS ABOUT
CONTINUING THE PROGRESS.
AND WE KNOW THEY HAVE NO PLAN TO
MAKE YOUR LIFE BETTER, SAFER AND
MORE PROSPEROUS.
SO INSTEAD, WHAT HAVE WE BEEN
WITNESSING?
DEMOCRATS HAVE SOME PRETTY
EXTREME ULTERIOR MOTIVES.
I'VE BEEN SOUNDING THE ALARM
ABOUT THIS FOR MONTHS RIGHT HERE
ON THIS SHOW.
WHEN DEMOCRATS TELL YOU WHAT
THEIR PLANS ARE, BELIEVE THEM.
MAXINE WATERS KEEP SAYING,
IMPEACH 45, IMPEACH 45.
OR, CLAIMING MY TIME.
AND OUR FELLOW DEMOCRATS KEEP
SAYING, MAXINE, DON'T TELL THEM.
WE WILL DO IT BUT DON'T TELL
THEM, KEEP QUIET.
KEEP IT A SECRET.
REMEMBER THIS.
>> I'M IN THIS FIGHT.
I'M IN THIS FIGHT AND I'M NOT
GOING TO MOVE AND AS YOU KNOW
THERE IS A DIFFERENCE IN HOW
SOME OF OUR LEADERSHIP TALKS
ABOUT HOW WE SHOULD HANDLE ALL
OF THIS.
THEY SEE MAXINE, PLEASE DON'T
SAY IMPEACHMENT ANYMORE.
AND WHEN THEY SAY THAT, I SAY
IMPEACHMENT, IMPEACHMENT,
IMPEACHMENT, IMPEACHMENT.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Sean: THAT'S COMING FROM A
CONGRESSWOMAN WHO WILL LIKELY
CHAIR A VERY POWERFUL HOUSE
COMMITTEE IF THE DEMOCRATS
REGAIN POWER.
AND ACTUALLY, ADAM SHIFTY, ADAM
SCHIFF ARE BRAGGING ABOUT THEIR
PLANS TO INITIATE ENDLESS
INVESTIGATIONS INTO THE
SO-CALLED RUSSIAN COLLUSION.
WE HAD TWO YEARS OF THIS
NONSENSE.
THE CHAIR OF THE ALL-POWERFUL
INTEL INTEL COMMITTEE, WATCH THE
LIAR, SHIFTY SHIFT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHILE THE REPUBLICANS WALKED
AWAY, THE DEMOCRATIC MINORITY
HAS CONTINUED.
THAT WORK WON'T STOP WHEN WE
TAKE THE MAJORITY BUT WE WILL BE
ABLE TO GET ANSWERS THE
REPUBLICANS WERE UNWILLING TO
PURSUE.
RECORDS THAT THE REPUBLICANS
WOULDN'T ASK FOR.
THE QUESTION IS THOUGH, I DON'T
KNOW WHETHER MUELLER HAS BEEN
ABLE TO ANSWER, OR THE RUSSIANS
MEN, LAUNDERING MONEY TO THE
TRUMP ORGANIZATION?
ON THAT WILL BE A VERY HIGH
PRIORITY TO GET AN ANSWER TO.
IF THEY WERE DOING THIS, IT'S
NOT ONLY A CRIME BUT IT'S
SOMETHING PROVABLE.
SOMETHING THAT THE RUSSIANS
COULD HOLD OVER THE HEAD OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> Sean: IT NEVER ENDS.
IT'S LIKE ON A REWIND.
THEY DON'T WANT TO INVESTIGATE
HILLARY, THE ONE THAT PAID FOR
PHONE HE RATIONALIZED THAT LIED
TO PFIZER COURT              FIS
TO PFIZER COURT              FIA
TO PFIZER COURT              FIC
TO PFIZER COURT              FIU
TO PFIZER COURT              FIT
TO PFIZER COURT              FIJ
TO PFIZER COURT              FID
TO PFIZER COURT              FIE
TO PFIZER COURT              FIS
TO PFIZER COURT              FIA
TO PFIZER COURT              FID
TO PFIZER COURT              FI,
TO PFIZER COURT              FIT
TO PFIZER COURT              FIE
TO PFIZER COURT              FIY
ONLY CARE ABOUT IF IT'S ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
AND IF YOU WANT TO VOTE FOR
DEMOCRATS TOMORROW, YOU ARE
VOTING TO RAISE YOUR TAXES.
90% OF A WORKING, YOU WANT TO
HIGHER TAXES, YOU WANT THE LIES
THAT ABOUT A MAN WHO HAS
LITERALLY SMEARED AND SLANDERED
AND BESMIRCHED, FOR NO DUE
PROCESS OR PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE, THEY WILL BLOCK ALL
JUDICIAL APPOINTMENTS.
KEEP YOUR DOCTOR.
KEEP YOUR PLAN AND PAY LESS.
WHAT A LIE?
IT'S THE BIGGEST LIE EVER TOLD
BY ANY ONE PARTY AND NOW THEY
ARE LITERALLY TRYING TO CAMPAIGN
ON THAT LIED.
THEY WANT TO PRESERVE OBAMACARE
FOR EVER, THAT'S WHAT IS AT
STAKE TOMORROW.
THEY WANT THE MANDATE TAX FOR
THE REPUBLICANS KILLED.
FOR THEM IT'S ABOUT POWER.
DON'T TALK ABOUT IT, CHANGE THE
TOPIC.
SANCTUARY CITIES, SANCTUARY
STATE TO ABOLISH ISA.
THEY ARE HIDING THEIR AGENDA FOR
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
SET UP AMERICA PROGRESS, THE
THINK TANK OF JOHN PODESTA.
JUST CHANGE THE TOPIC AS QUICKLY
AS YOU POSSIBLY CAN.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE LITERALLY
LISTENING BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
EVEN RUN ON WHAT THEY TRULY
BELIEVED.
THAT'S THE MODERN
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THIS IS YOUR CHOICE TONIGHT AND
THIS IS WHAT YOU WANT.
THAT'S THE AGENDA OF
NANCY PELOSI.
CHUCK SCHUMER.
YOU VOTE FOR ANY SENATE DEMOCRAT
AND YOU ARE VOTING FOR
CHUCK SCHUMER.
EVERYTHING TONIGHT IS UP FOR
GRABS AND THE GOOD NEWS IS YOU
HAVE THE POWER.
TONIGHT WE ARE WORKING ON THREE
DIFFERENT SCENARIOS, JUST SO YOU
KNOW.
SCENARIO NUMBER ONE, REPUBLICANS
CLAIMED THE MAJORITY IN THE
HOUSE.
AND GUESS WHAT, THAT'S A HUGE
WIN.
OPTION NUMBER TWO IS A SPLIT
DECISION.
THAT WOULD BE REPUBLICANS LOSING
THE HOUSE AND GAINING SEATS IN
THE SENATE.
WORST-CASE SCENARIO, WE WILL LET
THE FAKE NEWS GUYS TALK ABOUT
WHAT WOULD BE REPUBLICANS LOSING
THE HOUSE AND SENATE.
THAT WOULD MEAN WEDNESDAY
MORNING YOU WOULD HEAR SPEAKER
ELECT PELOSI.
THAT'S LITERALLY 36 TOSS UPS
THAT WOULD DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT
NANCY PELOSI GETS THAT GAVEL
BACK.
THESE ARE INCREDIBLY CLOSE
IMPORTANT RACES, LOOK AT THEM ON
OUR SCREEN.
WE ALSO HAVE THEM ON HANNITY
HANNITY.COMM.
NEW JERSEY, NEW YORK, VIRGINIA,
EVERYWHERE IN BETWEEN.
THE SITTING PRESIDENT ALMOST
ALWAYS SEES LOSSES IN THE HOUSE.
IN 2010, THE FIRST MIDTERM OF
BARACK HUSSEIN OBAMA, DEMOCRATS
LOST $0.63.
SEATS.
AND LEADING THE WAY BY
NEWT GINGRICH, THE REPUBLICANS
TOOK BY THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES.
BOTH OF THEM, OBAMA AND CLINTON,
TWO YEARS AFTER THOSE MIDTERMS
WENT ON TO WIN THE ELECTION.
OVER THE SENATE WE ARE WATCHING
A HANDFUL OF VERY CLOSE RACES
THAT WILL DETERMINE WHETHER OR
NOT CHUCK SCHUMER BECOMES THE
MAJORITY LEADER.
RIGHT HERE WHERE WE ARE TONIGHT
IN MISERY, WE ARE RIGHT NOW,
REPUBLICAN JOSH HAWLEY, AND FAR
LEFT SENATOR, WHO IS TRYING TO
CONVINCE THE GOOD PEOPLE OF
MISSOURI THAT SHE'S A MODERATE
BUT WE KNOW THAT'S NOT TRUE.
SHEEP VOTED AGAINST THE TAX CUTS
FOR THE PEOPLE OF MISSOURI AND
HER CAMPAIGN CAUGHT ON TAPE
LITERALLY SUPPORTING WIDESPREAD
GUN RESTRICTIONS AND GUN BANS
AND SHE'S NOT TELLING THEM.
REPUBLICAN, AMERICAN HERO,
MARTHA McSALLY.
IN IRAQ AND AFGHANISTAN, 28
YEARS OF SERVICE COMIC SALLY WAS
SERVING HER COUNTRY ABROAD, HER
OPPONENT, RADICAL LEFTIST
DEMOCRAT KYRSTEN SINEMA
ORGANIZING EVENTS WITH THE
RADICAL LAWYER FOR THE BLIND
SHAKE, LEADING ANTIWAR PROTEST
IN A PINK TUTU WITH A GROUP OF
WITCHES, AND I'M NOT MAKING THAT
UP.
SHE WAS MAKING THE CASE FOR IT,
IT'S OKAY IF AMERICANS WANT TO
FIGHT WITH THE TALIBAN.
AND AS OF THIS WEEKEND SHE STOOD
BY THIS STUPIDITY.
THOSE ARE OUR ENEMIES.
AND SHE CALLED ARIZONANS CRAZY,
THE METH LAB OF DEMOCRACY BUT
THEY ARE ONLY CRAZY AND LINDSAY
LOHAN WAY.
WE GO TO THE STATE OF INDIANA, A
TOSS-UP.
ACCORDING TO REPORTS, DONNELLY
HAS FUNDED SHADOW EFFORTS TO
FUND ADS FOR THE THIRD PARTY
LIBERTARIAN IN THE RACE AND HE
CAN'T WIN WITHOUT THE
LIBERTARIAN OF THAT RACE.
DIRTY POLITICS AT ITS WORST.
AND ONE MORE REMINDER BY THE WAY
THAT A VOTE FOR LIBERTARIAN IN
INDIANA IS A VOTE FOR DONNELLY
AND SCHUMER.
IN MONTANA THIS IS A STATE THAT
IS NOW IN PLAY.
REPUBLICAN MATT ROSENDALE
GAINING GROUND AGAINST JON
TESTER.
IN THE LATEST POLL, TESTER IS
DOWN BY THREE.
50% OF THE STATE VOTED IT WILL
ALL DEPEND ON TURNOUT TOMORROW.
TESTER VOTED WITH SCHUMER 87% OF
THE TIME, YOU MIGHT AS WELL HAVE
SCHUMER IN TENNESSEE, A VERY
IMPORTANT RACE.
MARSHALL        MARSHALL BLACKBU
MARSHALL        MARSHALL BLACKBN
MARSHALL        MARSHALL BLACKBS
MARSHALL        MARSHALL BLACKBO
MARSHALL        MARSHALL BLACKBL
MARSHALL        MARSHALL BLACKBD
MARSHALL        MARSHALL BLACKBW
MARSHALL        MARSHALL BLACKBN
MARSHALL        MARSHALL BLACKB,
BUT ANYTHING COULD HAPPEN.
IN NEVADA, RACES ARE ALWAYS
CLOSE.
REPUBLICAN SENATOR DEAN HELLER
IN A MUST HOLD SEAT FOR THE
REPUBLICANS.
WE WILL HAVE AN ACTUAL RACE ON
HER HANDS AND WEST VIRGINIA
BETWEEN INCUMBENT DEMOCRAT JOE
MANCHIN AND PATRICK MORRISSEY.
AND IN FLORIDA, LET ME BE BLUNT.
EVERYTHING IN FLORIDA IS AS
USUAL TOO CLOSE TO CALL.
DEMOCRATIC DO-NOTHING SCHUMER,
DEMOCRAT BILL NELSON AGAINST
RICK SCOTT WHO HAS BEEN THERE
AGAIN AND AGAIN FOR THE PEOPLE
OF FLORIDA.
IN FLORIDA THE GUBERNATORIAL
RACE ALSO SO TIGHT BETWEEN RON
DeSANTIS AND CORRUPT
SOCIALISTS.
BY THE WAY, WOULDN'T IT BE GREAT
IF WE COULD GET FROM AN FBI
INVESTIGATOR FREE TICKETS TO
HAMILTON AND FREE VACATIONS LIKE
GILLAM, AND THE WORST CRIME RATE
IN ALL OF FLORIDA.
REPUBLICANS -- BY THE WAY, DO
YOU GUYS LIKE ELTON JOHN?
JUST CHECKING.
IT'S A MASSIVE TURNOUT TOMORROW.
THAT'S ALL IT IS.
WE WILL GET THE GOVERNMENT WE
DESERVE.
KEEPING OUR EYES ALSO ON A
POTENTIAL SHOCKER OF ALL PLACES,
IN NEW JERSEY.
BOB YOU AGAIN, A MARINE, SEMPER
FI, BOB.
CLOSER THAN ANYONE PREDICTED.
AND IN THE GREAT STATE OF TEXAS,
TED CRUZ HAS MAINTAINED A STUDY
LEAD AGAINST BOZO OVERWORKED.
EVEN THOUGH THIS DEMOCRAT HAS
LITERALLY ALMOST GOTTEN A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO THROW
AT THE GREATEST
CONSTITUTIONALIST IN THE U.S.
SENATE.
TEXAS, DON'T LET SOMEBODY WHO
DOESN'T HAVE TEXAS VALUES WIN
TEXAS.
TED CRUZ NEEDS TO BE BACK IN THE
U.S. SENATE.
TOMORROW'S VOTE WILL BE CRUCIAL.
DEMOCRATS ACROSS THE COUNTRY,
BENEFITED.
I'M LOOKING ALL OVER THERE, FAKE
NEWS.
THE MAIN STREET MEDIA, THE
BIGGEST OWNERS OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THEY SPEAK WITH ONE VOICE AT
THIS POINT AND SAY THE MOST
HATEFUL, DISGUSTING, DESPICABLE
ANTI-TRUMPED VITRIOL THAT THIS
COUNTRY HAS EVER SEEN.
THEY HAVE BEEN WORSE THAN EVER
AND WE HAVE THE TAPE TO PROVE
IT, TAKE A LOOK.
>> IF TRUMP WINS HE WILL CAST IT
AS A COMPLETE ENDORSEMENT OF HIS
MOST UNDEMOCRATIC BEHAVIOR.
IF YOU ARE 18 AND THAT HAPPENS,
YOU STAND IN VERY WELL CHANCE OF
NOT LIVING IN A WESTERN-STYLE
DEMOCRACY FOR PART OR ALL OF
YOUR LIFE.
>> HE IS A RACIST PIG.
>> HE'S TALKING ABOUT WHITE
SUPREMACIST IDEOLOGY.
WE ARE NOT ONLY ON A DANGEROUS
SLIPPERY SLOPE, WE FALL IN.
>> IF YOU HAD A KID THAT HAD
As AND B'S ON THE REPORT CARD,
DOING WELL WITH THEIR TRUMPET
LESSONS BUT ALSO HAPPEN TO BE
SELLING METH OUT OF THE
BASEMENT, HE WOULD SAY, HOLD ON
A SECOND.
I CAN'T JUST TALK ABOUT THE GOOD
STUFF, I GOT A PROBLEM WITH THIS
KID.
>> RACISM, XENA PHONE AND
XENOPHOBIA, ALL THESE THINGS I
THOUGHT WERE STIGMATIZED BUT
DONALD TRUMP HAS BROUGHT THEM
OUT OF THE CLOSET.
>> WHAT DONALD TRUMP DID WAS
NORMALIZE RACISM.
HE NORMALIZED OVERTLY RACIST
BEHAVIOR.
>> Sean: HOW DESPICABLE ON
"SATURDAY NIGHT LIVE" WITH A
SO-CALLED COMEDIAN MAKING FUN OF
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSIONAL
CANDIDATE DAN CRENSHAW?
A HERO WHO LOST HIS EYE WHILE
SERVING OUR GREAT COUNTRY AS A
NAVY SEAL IN AFGHANISTAN.
BY THE WAY, ALL OF YOU ON
"SATURDAY NIGHT LIVE" CAN GO
STRAIGHT TO HELL OVER THIS.
YOU OWE THIS MAN A PROFUSE
APOLOGY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> DAN CRENSHAW [LAUGHTER]
>> COME ON, MAN.
>> YOU MAY BE SURPRISED TO HEAR
HE IS A CONGRESSIONAL CANDIDATE
FROM TEXAS AND NOT A HIT MAN IN
A MOVIE.
I'M SORRY, I KNOW HE LOST HIS
EYE IN WAR WHATEVER [LAUGHTER]
>> Sean: HONESTLY THAT CROSS
THE A LINE, WAY BEYOND IT.
THEY OWE HIM A MASSIVE APOLOGY.
DAN CRENSHAW TO HIS CREDIT IS
TAKING THE HIGH ROAD.
HE'S NOT DEMANDING ON A PHONY
APOLOGY WHICH IS WHAT IT WOULD
BE ANYWAY.
AND TONIGHT HE REPRESENTS
EVERYTHING THAT'S GREAT ABOUT
THIS COUNTRY.
EVERYTHING GREAT ABOUT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WE ARE HERE IN MISSOURI AND CAPE
GIRARDEAU.
PEOPLE THAT WORK HARD, PLAYED BY
THE RULES, PAY THEIR TAXES,
RAISE THEIR KIDS AND OBEY THE
LAWS AND FRANKLY GOT LEFT BEHIND
BY CORRUPT GOVERNMENT WHERE
POLITICIANS JUST WANT THEIR
POWER.
FINALLY GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN
WORKING FOR THE FORGOTTEN MEN
AND WOMEN OF THIS COUNTRY.
LIKE THE LEFT, BY THE WAY?
YOU KNOW WHAT, HE'S NOT PLAYING
THE POLITICS OF VICTIMIZATION.
HE WON'T GIVE INTO THE GUTTER
LEVEL ATTACKS OF NBC.
ARE YOU PROUD OF THAT TOM
BROKAW?
WHERE IS TOM BROKAW SPEAKING OUT
ABOUT THIS?
WHERE IS ANYBODY IN FAKE NEWS,
CONSPIRACY TV OR MSNBC?
ARE YOU GOING TO VILIFY THOSE
DISGUSTING REMARKS?
YOU DON'T HAVE THE COURAGE TO
SPEAK OUT?
AND WHILE DEMOCRATS CALL EVERY
CONSERVATIVE RACIST, SEXIST,
XENOPHOBIC, ISLAMOPHOBIC, DIRTY
AIR, DIRTY WATER, THROAT GRANNY
OVER THE CLIFF AND KILL
CHILDREN.
THEY DO IT EVERY TWO YEARS AND
EVERY FOUR YEARS.
YOU ASK YOURSELF WHICH SIDE YOU
ARE ON.
THE SIDE OF THE DECORATED WAR
HERO'S LIKE MARTHA McSALLY AND
DAN CRENSHAW?
I KNOW THE PEOPLE AND CAPE
GIRARDEAU ARE.
ARE YOU SUPPORTING REGULATIONS
AND SUPPORTING WHAT HAS BEEN AN
ECONOMIC BOOM THAT WE HAVE NOT
SEEN IN OVER TEN YEARS?
DO YOU WANT SECURE BORDERS?
YOU WANT ON A WALL WITH A DOOR
AND A MAN THAT WE RESPECT WITH
OUR SOVEREIGNTY AND OUR BORDERS
THAT PEOPLE COME IN LEGALLY?
YOU WANT THE POLICIES OF
SANCTUARY CITIES AND SANCTUARY
STATES?
YOU BELIEVE IN PEACE THROUGH
STRENGTH?
DO YOU VALUE DUE PROCESS?
PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE?
DO YOU LOVE OUR CONSTITUTION AND
OUR AMERICAN VALUES THAT MADE
THIS COUNTRY SO GREAT?
THE PEOPLE THAT MAKE THIS
COUNTRY SO GREAT?
OR DO YOU SUPPORT THOSE ON THE
LEFT THAT DO NOTHING BUT SMEAR,
SLANDER, BESMIRCH, CLAIM CALL,
PLOT POLITICAL REVENGE AND
OBSTRUCT THE PRESIDENT'S AGENDA?
THEY HAVE NO PLAN TO MAKE YOUR
LIFE BETTER.
THEY ATTEMPT THEY AFTER DAY AND
HOUR AFTER HOUR TO DIVIDE THIS
COUNTRY ANYWAY THEY CAN.
TODAY AT MULTIPLE CAMPAIGNS
STOPS, PRESIDENT TRUMP
HIGHLIGHTED WHAT IS A CLEAR
CHOICE AND A CONTRAST BETWEEN
THE PARTIES AND A VISION FOR THE
FUTURE.
AND HE WILL BE MAKING HIS FINAL
PITCH RIGHT AFTER THE SHOW TO
VOTERS.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
SPEAK TO EVERYTHING WE HAVE
CREATED AND ACHIEVED IS AT STAKE
ON ELECTION DAY.
IT IS.
IF THE RADICAL DEMOCRATS TAKE
POWER, THEY WILL TAKE A WRECKING
BALL TO OUR ECONOMY AND TO OUR
FUTURE.
THE DEMOCRAT AGENDA IS A
SOCIALIST NIGHTMARE FOR OUR
COUNTRY.
THE REPUBLICAN AGENDA IS THE
AMERICAN DREAM AND THAT IS WHAT
WE ARE DOING.
WE ARE BRINGING BACK THE
AMERICAN DREAM.
THEY WANT TO RAISE YOUR TAXES,
THE DEMOCRATS DO.
RESTORE CRIPPLING REGULATIONS
AND SHUTDOWN YOUR NEW STEEL
MEALS.
TAKE AWAY YOUR HEALTH CARE AND
PUT ILLEGAL ALIENS BEFORE
AMERICAN CITIZENS, THAT'S WHAT
THEY WANT.
DEMOCRATS ARE INVITING CARAVAN
AFTER CARAVAN OF ILLEGAL ALIENS
TO POUR INTO OUR COUNTRY
OVERWHELMING THE SCHOOLS, THE
HOSPITALS AND AT YOUR COMMUNITY
IS.
THERE IS ONLY ONE WAY TO STOP
THIS DEMOCRAT LED ASSAULT ON
AMERICAN SOVEREIGNTY.
YOU HAVE TO VOTE REPUBLICAN
TOMORROW.
YOU HAVE TO.
I'M ASKING EVERY CITIZEN FROM
EVERY PARTY, EVERY BACKGROUND
AND EVERY RACE, COLOR AND CREED
TO REJECT THE DEMOCRAT POLITICS
OF ANGER AND DIVISION AND TO
UNITE BEHIND OUR PROUD AND
RIGHTEOUS DESTINY AS AMERICANS
ALTOGETHER.
>> Sean: IN JUST A FEW SHORT
HOURS, YOU HAVE THE POWER TO
SHOCK THE WORLD AGAIN.